R
INSCRIBED ON THE MEMORIAL WALL.
PRINCE HARRY AND MEGHAN MARKLE
ARE WELCOMING THEIR DAUGHTER
INTO THE FAMILY, HER NAME IS
LILIBET "LILI" DIANA
MOUNTBATTEN-WINDSOR CUT.
SHE IS THE 2ND CHILD TO THE
DUKE AND DUCHESS OF SUSSEX.
THEIR FIRST IS ARCHIE, BORN IN
2019.
ACROSS THE POND MEMBERS OF THE
ROYAL FAMILY EXTENDING THEIR
GREETINGS.
PRINCE CHARLES AND CAMILLA
TWEETING CONGRATULATIONS TO
HARRY, MEGHAN AND ARCHIE ON THE
ARRIVAL OF BABY LILIBET "LILI"
DIANA MOUNTBATTEN-WINDSOR
HUSTLE, WISHING THEM ALL THE
BEST IN THE SPECIAL TIME.
PRINCE WILLIAM AND KATE
MIDDLETON WROTE QUOTE, WE ARE
ALL DELIGHTED BY THE HAPPY NEWS
OF THE ARRIVAL OF BABY LILY,
CONGRATULATIONS TO HARRY,
MEGHAN AND ARCHIE.
PULLOVER CAM AND IS UNSCENTED
BARBARA CALIFORNIA WHERE BABY
LILLY WAS BORN.
BUT FIRST LET'S GO TO OUR ROYAL
CORRESPONDENT MAX FOSTER WHO
TELLS US THE SPECIAL MEANING
BEHIND LILIES NAME.
>> REALLY BETH WAS BORN ON
FRIDAY AND MOTHER AND BABY ARE
BACK HOME ALREADY.
THEY'RE BOTH DOING WELL.
HEALTHY.
ACCORDING TO A STATEMENT FROM
THE SUSSEX HOUSEHOLD.
EVERYTHING SEEMS TO HAVE GONE
TO PLAN.
REALLY BET IS NAMED AFTER THE
QUEEN WHOSE NICKNAME IS LILIBET,
SHE COULD NOT SAY HER NAME
PROPERLY, ELIZABETH AS A CHILD,
THAT'S WHAT LEGEND SAYS ANYWAY,
BUT THIS BABY WILL BE CALLED
LILY.
HER MIDDLE NAME IS DIANA, ALSO
NAMED AFTER HARRY'S LATE MOTHER
AS WELL.
A REAL NOD TO THE BRITISH ROYAL
FAMILY.
HARRY'S --
THEY'VE SAID PREVIOUSLY THE
REALLY GOING TO HAVE TO.
HARRY SUGGESTED IT WAS FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL REASONS.
WE DO SEEM TO HAVE THE FULL SET
NOW OF FORCE A SUCCESS LIVING
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE REST OF THE BRITISH SIDE OF
THE FAMILY ISSUED A STATEMENT,
THE QUEEN, PRINCE OF WALES, THE
DUKE AND DUCHESS OF CAMBRIDGE
HAVE BEEN INFORMED AND ARE
DELIGHTED WITH THE NEWS OF THE
BIRTH OF A DAUGHTER FOR DUKE
AND DUCHESS OF SUSSEX.
MAX FOSTER, CNN, HAMPSHIRE,
ENGLAND.
>> HARRY AND MEGHAN WELCOMING
BABY LILY OR LILIBET LILIBET
"LILI" DIANA
MOUNTBATTEN-WINDSOR PAYING
HOMAGE TO BELIEVE THE QUEEN AND
PRINCESS DIANA.
SHE WAS BORN HERE AT COTTAGE
HOSPITAL INCENTIVE BARBARA, AND
A PUBLICIST FOR MEGHAN MARKLE
SAYING TO US THAT THE FAMILY IS
SETTLING IN AT HOME.
EVERYONE IS HEALTHY AND
CONFIRMING THAT ARCHIE IS GLAD
TO BE HAVING A LITTLE SISTER.
AT THIS HOSPITAL, BORN IN ONE
OF THOSE UPSCALE BIRTHING ROOMS
WITH THE SOFA AND RECLINER AND
THE OTHER CHAIR, THE BED,
WHATNOT.
I WAS SPEAKING WITH A FORMER
ROYAL WATCHER IN THE UK WHO HAS
NOW MOVED TO THIS AREA AND HE
LIVES BY THE MARKLE'S IN --
HE SAID ONE OF THE THINGS ABOUT
THEM IS THEY WANT TO PRESERVE
THEIR ANONYMITY AND THEY'VE
BEEN ABLE TO DO SO AND THEY
DESCRIBE HOW HE THINKS SOME
RATHER UPSCALE GUESTS MAY DROP
OF BABY GIFTS.
>> I FULLY EXPECT THEM TO GO
OVER, OPRAH AND ELLEN WITH BABY
PRESENCE, I'M SURE THEY'LL BE
ABSOLUTELY BOMBARDED WITH
CHRISTENING GIFTS.
SO WE WILL SEE MORE, HOPEFULLY
AND YOU COURSE.
>> IF YOU ARE SAYING TO
YOURSELF HOW DID THEY HAVE A
BABY HERE WITHOUT THE PAPARAZZI
STALKING THEM?
THE ENTRANCE, EXIT?
WELL, THAT'S VERY MUCH A
STRATEGY HERE AMONG THE ROYAL
COUPLE.
THEY WANTED TO MOVE TO
CALIFORNIA AND HAVE MUCH MORE
OF A PRIVATE LIFE AND MANY
EXPERTS SAY THERE AREN'T A
NUMBER OF PAPARAZZI
PHOTOGRAPHERS CHASING THEM ALL
AROUND HERE.
UNCOVER CAMERON FROM MONTECITO.
BACK TO YOU.
>> PAUL, THANK YOU.
WE SPOKE WITH TRISH OF, THE
BRITISH TALKS SHOW HOST ABOUT
THE MEANING OF LILIBET "LILI"
DIANA MOUNTBATTEN-WINDSOR'S
NAME.
WE ASKED HER IF NAMING HER
AFTER THE QUEEN IS AN OVERTURE
TO THE BUCKINGHAM PALACE.
HERE'S WHAT SHE SAID.
>> HARRY AND THE QUEEN HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN VERY CLOSE, THEY'VE
ALWAYS BEEN VERY, VERY CLOSE.
IT'S INTERESTING TO NOTE THAT
THE QUEEN DOES A VERY CLOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THOSE
MEMBERS OF HER FAMILY WHO WERE
ACTIVELY SERVING IN THE ARMED
FORCES AS OF COURSE HARRY WAS.
HE DID 2 TOURS, AS ANDY DID
PRINCE ANDREW.
AND HER OWN HUSBAND, OF COURSE
THE LATE PRINCE PHILIP WHO IS
ACTIVELY SERVING.
SHE'S ALWAYS HAD THAT REALLY --
DO YOU REMEMBER THEY DID THAT
LITTLE SKIT WHERE HARRY SORT OF
DID THE MIC DROP AND WE HAVE.
YOU I THINK LILIBET BEING THAT
PET NAME THAT PRINCE PHILIP HAD
FOR THE QUEEN, IT'S PROBABLY
SOMETHING THEY'VE HAD IN MIND
FOR SOME TIME.
OF COURSE DIANA, IT WAS ALWAYS
GOING TO BE DIANA AS THE MIDDLE
NAME.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT,
BECAUSE AS YOU POINT OUT,
THEY'VE ALSO NAMED THEIR
DAUGHTER IN HONOR AFTER PRINCE
HARRY'S LATE MOTHER.
LET'S LISTEN TO PRINCE HARRY
TALK ABOUT HOW HE STRUGGLED
WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE AFTER HER
DEATH.
>> I WANTED TO DRINK.
AND WANTED TO TAKE DRUGS.
I WAS WANTING TO TRY TO DO THE
THINGS THAT MADE ME FEEL LESS
LIKE I WAS FEELING.
I FOUND MYSELF DRINKING, NOT
BECAUSE I WAS ENJOYING IT, BUT
BECAUSE I WAS TRYING TO MASK
SOMETHING.
>> WE DO YOU THINK IT MEANS FOR
HIM TO HONOR HIS MOTHER LIKE
THIS?
>> IT WAS SO SAD.
SO SAD.
HE HAS BEEN VERY OPEN AND
HONEST ABOUT HOW HE STRUGGLED
WITH THE LOSS OF HIS MOTHER, AS
I AM SURE HAS PRINCE WILLIAM,
BUT THEY ARE VERY DIFFERENT
PERSONALITIES.
IT WAS ALWAYS GOING TO BE ON
THE CARDS.
OF COURSE REMEMBER DIANA WOULD
HAVE BEEN 60 ON JULY THE 1ST,
WHICH IS THE DAY THAT THEY WERE
DUE TO UNVEIL THE STATUE IN HER
HONOR IN KENSINGTON GARDENS.
AND SO NOW THAT THE BABY IS
BORN, I'M SURE PRINCE HARRY
WILL HAVE TIME.
I THINK HE WILL BE EVEN MORE
WANTING TO BE THERE AT THE
UNVEILING OF THE STATUE,
BECAUSE HE IS NOW STARTING --
HIS HAS SPOKEN OUT ABOUT THE
GRIEF HE WENT THROUGH WITH HIS
MOTHER.
I THINK IT'S OUT THERE IN THE
OPEN.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO FEEL A
LOT MORE COMFORTABLE AND